ready player one Steven Spielberg's
adaptation of Ernest Cline's
best-selling novel has finally arrived
in theaters from its dazzling opening
sequence to its epic final battle the
film is absolutely packed with decades
upon decades of pop-culture references
but while some are just fun Easter eggs
others actually serve a plot function in
the grand finale we're here to sort it
all out as we explain the ending of
ready player one the ultimate videogame
showdown for ready player once finale
only the biggest pop culture packed
showdown would do so pars of all also
known by his real name of Wade Watts
takes action putting out an open call
for help to the entire world setting the
stage for the ultimate battle inside the
virtual universe known as the Oasis
taking place on planet doom from the
Voltron cartoons the battle involves
everyone from the Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles to Chucky himself who goes on a
murder spree perhaps unmatched in his
own franchise after the evil Nolan
Sorento summons Mechagodzilla to his
system he's taken down by Dai tow who
pilots the iconic rx-78 tube Gundam from
Mobile Suit Gundam after being dropped
off on the planet by serenity from
Firefly perhaps the best part just as
the evil eye rock is about to kill the
good guys show takes him out using the
ultimate 80s weapon the glaive from
Kroll nice a magic spell a whole battle
is staged in order to help Parrs of all
and his friends get inside Castle anorak
which is covered by a magic spell
summoned by the powerful orb of OC Vox
luckily the team has someone on the
inside
Artemis who is able to take down the
shield by uttering the magic incantation
that's summoned it here's the kicker the
spell is actually a quote from the 1981
fantasy film Excalibur known as the
charm of making a spell spoken by both
Merlin and Morgana lafay who knew right
have you forgotten the charm of making
oof a spy food is 10v the value of an
extra life even after the orb is
deactivated in the battle seemingly lost
Sorento isn't ready to quit instead he
uses the Cataclysm artifact which
unleashes a mega bomb that instantly
kills every avatar on the entire planet
every avatar except as it turns out
Parsa vols why well earlier in the film
parsable had won a bet with the robotic
curator of the holiday journals an
archive that documents all the pop
culture obsessions of oasis founder
James Halliday the reward for winning
the bet was an old quarter which in
classic videogame terms could be used
for an extra life to keep playing on in
arcade game after you died thanks to
having his extra life parseval's avatar
was resurrected and he was able to
complete holidays final puzzle
the original Easter Egg after all of
that trouble to get their holidays final
challenge seems deceptively simple
vintage television an Atari 2600 console
and playing the right game in the right
way the game is the 1979 classic
adventure and the trick which pars of
all immediately understands is that
you're not actually supposed to win the
game you're just supposed to find the
Easter Egg hidden inside it it's not
just any Easter Egg though it's
literally the first video game Easter
Egg as the very term Easter Egg was
coined to describe the secret message in
the game which reads created by Warren
Robinett a movie about Easter eggs which
has an Easter Egg about the first Easter
Egg now that's truly meta one last test
even after he's won the final keep ours
of all challenge isn't over the last
test comes when anorak offers parsable a
contract telling him all he has to do is
sign and the Oasis will be his pars of
all refuses to sign though because he
realizes it's a test Halliday played by
Mark Rylance has forced his partner
ogden morrow played by simon pegg to
sign a similar contract and regretted it
for the rest of his life fittingly the
test is an echo of a similar morality
test that plays out at the end of the
classic film Willy Wonka and the
Chocolate Factory from which the plot of
ready player one is borrowed
good day the true Easter egg when he
completes the third challenge and passes
anoraks contract test
parsable is indeed granted control of
the Oasis but the true price represented
by a literal giant glowing egg isn't
money or fame it's holidays belief that
connecting with real people in the real
world is more important than anything
you might do in an imaginary online
fantasy world Wade finally comes to
agree which is how and why he wins in
the end the lesson is driven home when
pars of all emerges from the real world
to find holidays one-time partner and
best friend
aughh morrow waiting for him it turns
out morrow had secretly been monitoring
the competition through his own oasis
avatar the curator of the holiday
journals who gave parse of all the extra
life he needed to win in a symbolic
gesture
Wade honors what he's learned from
Halladay by hiring maro back as an oasis
consultant finally repairing the rift
that cost Halladay his best friend
taking the leap as the new owner of the
Oasis Wade is suddenly the most powerful
person in the world but he uses his
powers for good
putting the lessons he's learned from
holiday into play he and his friends get
Sorrento arrested for ordering the
murder of Wade's aunt then he orders
that the Oasis be shut down two days a
week to force people back into the real
world and finally he does what Halladay
couldn't and kisses the girl winning
Artemis as the ultimate prize because in
the end love is the ultimate Easter egg
or something thanks for watching click
the looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]